نحن الان في المناطق الجنوبيه الغربيه من
الخرطوم العاصمه بالتحديد في منطقه
الكلاكله القبه عموما هذه المناطق هي
بعيده من العمليات العسكريه نوعا ما وليست
فيها عمليات متاخمه
في هذه المنطقه لكن لكنها تعرضت للقصد
تلاحظون الان خلفي هذه واحد من المنازل
التي تدمرت
بالكامل بفعل القصف هذه البيوت اغلب هذه
المناطق البيوت التي فيها هي بيوت شعبيه
وليست فيها نوعيه الخرسانه التي تبنى بها
البيوت الحديثه يعني نوعيه البيوت تبنى من
الطوب ومن الطين كما تلاحظون حتى ان سقفها
وسقف بسيط وليس من الخرسانه
والاسمنت وهذه البيوت تعرضت لقصف هذا
المنزل تعرض اهله للقصف عدد كما عرفنا من
اهل المنطقه انهم الان يتداون يتداون
ويستشفون في المستشفى القريب هنا في هذه
المنطقه نوعا ما الحركه والمستشفيات جزء
من المستشفيات يعمل
حسب ما عرفنا ان هناك ثلاثه عشر منزلا
تعرض
للقصفه وانه تضرر بفعل القصف في هذه
المنطقه نتيجه الاشتباكات الدائره ما بين
قوات الدعم السريع وما بين الجيش السوداني
الاحياء هنا ما زال الهلع يسيطر على سكان
هذه المنطقه الذين التقينا بهم نلاحظ في
الشاشه الان ان عدد من سكان هذه المنطقه
يتضافرون في الجهود لترميم اثار القذف
التي لحقت بالسوري منزلهم ويعملون في
محاوله
[موسيقى]
اعاده البناء لهذا الصوره التي تطرف في
القصف من الناحيه الاخرى هذا هذا المنزل
نزل برمته على العدو سوي بالارض سنحاول ان
ندخل هذا المنزل الذي تضرر جزئيا بسبب
القصف في هذه المنطقه ونلتقي باهله لنعرف
ما الذي جرى بالنسبه لهم هذا هو رب هذه
الاسره
تعرض ما زالت الامور بالنسبه له هو يعني
هناك اثار متضرر يعني هل لنا هل صحتك جيده
تعرضت ببعض ما زالت يعني هناك اثار القصف
والاجزاء والجروح التي ما زلت تتداوى بها
يعني ما الذي جرى لك والله نحن ضربت في
البيت باعتباره في البيت نحن جوا البيت
وقمنا جارين لجوه باعتبار محل الغزيف
والحاجات
الحته الباب قافل يلا باقي الحديد
والجزائر دي والحاجات دي كلها دقت فينا
نتعرف ايضا على اهل المنطقه الذين هم في
هذه المنطقه يعني بالنسبه للسكان الذي
تضررت منازلهم بماذا يفكرون وبماذا يخططون
والله طبعا هما الناس ما عندها حاجه
تعملها
قاعدين الضربه
ربنا يعيننا بس
رخيصه يا رب العالمين هل ستبقونا في هذه
البيوت بهذه الشاكله ام انكم تخططون
لترميمها او للخروج منها والله طبعا ما
عندنا حاجه نقدر نعمل نقدر نعمرها
بس
الذعر التمسناه من سكان هذه المنطقه
يقولون انهم ليس لهم علاقه بما يجري وما
يحصل ويتمنون ان تتوقف هذه الحرب السريعا
حتى يعيش المواطنون باطمئنان وامان وسلام